So one of the things about-- remarkable things about science is, usually no model is
completely correct. Because of
biology and evolution,
organisms do the most amazing, crazy things,
and so they almost can make any model work.
There will be an organism out there that will fit a model.
And so there is now some recent evidence where environment can effect the
progeny.
An example would be the recent discovery of a novel
bacterial immune system,
where bacteria that are exposed to a
virus take a piece of that virus and put it into its
own chromosomes, as a then heritable marker that they
have been in their past,
exposed to that virus, such that when the
progeny of those parental cells that were exposed to the virus,
are then exposed to the virus,
they're going to be resistant to it.
And so there is a case where environment is changing the genetic material,
which is then being propagated on.
It's an exception,
so it doesn't say that,
you know,
but it's certainly not the driving force for most of evolution,
as Lamarck postulated it.
But there are examples now coming up where the genetic material somehow does respond to
environment and adapts itself to maybe make the progeny more fit,
in that sense.